[Musique]
je ne suis pas venu vous parler des
technologies de l'intelligence
artificielle
je suis venu vous partagez un regard une
vision sur notre capacité à nous en
saisir pour nous émanciper
j'aimerais que ce soir en sortant vous
sachiez comment vous voudriez vous en
servir pour être plus libre mais tout
d'abord je vous propose un petit jeu je
vous invite à fermer les yeux et à vous
projeter chez vous dans vos tâches
quotidiennes
lorsque vous y êtes
je vous invite à chercher la tâche
l'activité qui vous est la plus ingrate
la plus difficile
je vois que vous l'avez moi pour me
faire pardonner je vous invite à
chercher sont opposés c'est à dire la
chose qui vous épanouir le plus dans
votre vie un jour quelques sourires
merci beaucoup je vous invite à garder
ça en tête jusqu'à la fin de la
discussion
je ne sais pas si vous l'avez remarqué
mais l'intelligence artificielle c'est
devenu une espèce de grosse tarte à la
crème médiatique on en parle de plus en
plus pour les entreprises c'est un
véritable eldorado un pas rater
pour moi je vois ça comme la poule aux
oeufs d'or et le magicien d'oz réunis je
ne sais pas si vous le savez mais ça
donne quand même des années 60 et ce qui
change aujourd'hui c'est que
l'intelligence artificielle commencent à
sortir des laboratoires se répand à
grande échelle dans votre smartphone
vous objets connectés où elles vont
pouvoir apprendre sur vos données ou de
manière plus visible comme les robots
les drones ou bien sûr la voiture
autonome qui n'est qu'un robot dans
lequel on peut rentrer d'ailleurs qu'il
faut savoir avec l'intelligence
artificielle c'est que c'est en fait un
grand domaine scientifique que l'on
range dans les sciences cognitives
celles qui s'intéressent à la pensée et
à la connaissance et ce qui est amusant
avec l'intelligence artificielle c'est
que ces frontières se décale au fur et à
mesure qu'elle progresse ce que l'on
considère aujourd'hui comme de
l'intelligence artificielle ne le sera
pas forcément demain ce que je dois vous
dire c'est que l'intelligence
artificielle en fait est constitué d'un
tas de sous domaines
qui tente de faire une chose
c'est-à-dire refaire ce que vous et moi
nous savons déjà faire comme nos sens
nos mouvements ou des choses plus
complexes comme calculé écrire parler
dessinée et même imaginer liane lequin
le synthétise bien en disant que
l'intelligence artificielle s'est fait
refaire aux machines ce que l'on
attribue généralement aux animaux et aux
humains alors j'aimerais bien l'étendre
à l'ensemble du monde biologique parce
que on voit apparaître des projets de
robots pollinisateurs glyphosate prouve
cela et et j'aimerais bien voir là
l'intelligence collaborative de certains
végétaux bientôt reprise par des
intelligences artificielles
alors pour réfléchir à lire deux choses
me semblent importantes la première
c'est que jusque là les technologies
nous était subordonnée on programmait
nous mêmes leur décision aujourd'hui on
peut les rendre bien plus autonome on
leur a appris à faire on leur a appris à
apprendre à prendre des décisions seul
vous voyez le changement mais
rassurons-nous pour le moment elles
prennent ces décisions uniquement dans
des tâches bien circonscrite car la
deuxième chose à savoir c'est que
l'intelligence artificielle reste bien
différente de la nôtre pour pouvoir
comparer l'intelligence artificielle et
l'intelligence humaine
j'ai souhaité représenter le champ des
compétences cognitives sur sous forme
d'un spectre comme celui de la lumière
à ce moment là on peut voir que les
intelligences artificielles sont en fait
tout un tas de petites fonctions
répartis sur le continuum cognitif une
intelligence artificielle qui a appris à
décrire des images ne pourra que
d'écrire des images elle prend ses
décisions dans son contexte
dans le petit monde qu'on lui a donnée à
apprendre
pour se représenter une intelligence
fluide comme celle de l'homme mieux de
la femme
il faudrait rajouter quelques dimension
supplémentaire celle pour tout les
interconnexions foisonnante entre toutes
ces compétences
ensuite les émotions et pour finir la
conscience on est donc loin d'une
éventuelle intelligence d'artificiel
général qui saurait comprendre et
interagir avec notre monde
pourtant je trouve qu'on l'a médiatise
beaucoup dans la fontaine et c'est
l'arbre qui cache la forêt coeur on
sous-estiment pas mal l'importance des
intelligences artificielles qui existent
déjà ils veulent qu'ils peuvent
profondément bouleversé notre monde on
passe parfois à côté des questions
subtile qu'elle soulève donc à ces
intelligences artificielles tout
autonome qu'elle soit reste pensée est
programmée par des hommes alors comment
éviter les éventuels biais tels que le
sexisme mais aussi les préjugés sur
l'âge votre parcours scolaire
il faut savoir que par exemple que les
intelligences artificielles de
reconnaissance d'image ont le plus grand
mal à reconnaître les visages des femmes
noires
soit on les voit pas soit elles sont
parfois taxé de gori un petit peu moyen
on a aussi on est à l'heure de l'afrique
news qui a révélé une sorte de grande
guerre de la vérité et je ne sais pas
comment on va faire avec ces nouveaux
algorithmes qui viennent de sortir très
évolués qui ont la capacité de générer
des images qui trompe les meilleurs
systèmes de reconnaissance d'image mais
surtout qu'ils peuvent duper les humains
vous imaginez le potentiel de
manipulation comment va ton utilisé
l'intelligence artificielle par rapport
à l'emploi
va-t-on les utilisent et enfin pour
lutter contre nos désastre écologique
ont-elles sauver des vies ou l'un vertes
les enjeux sont tels ils me crois qu'on
ne peut pas laisser aux simples
chercheurs et aux et aux experts la
responsabilité est vraiment trop lourde
encore moins aux grandes entreprises qui
portent ces technologies
elles ne sont certainement pas les mieux
placés pour défendre l'intérêt général
il n'ya que nous et on peut faire des
choses formidables avec l'intelligence
artificielle un problème touche
particulièrement le projet dix personnes
a appris sur 700 mille dossiers à faire
des prédictions médical parfois mieux
que les médecins en particulier pour la
schizophrénie
vous imaginez un diagnostic précoce ce
que ça peut représenter comme confort de
vie pour les patients et leurs familles
ou mieux encore un algorithme est
capable de poser un diagnostic précoce
pour le cancer de la peau juste à partir
de photos quand on sait les risques pour
le mélanome
on imagine le nombre de vies sauvées
croyez-moi on peut faire des choses
également bien plus troublantes
un exemple m'a frappé dernièrement une
grande entreprise chinoise décidé de
suivre en temps réel les ondes
cérébrales de ses employés ils ont des
casquettes bardée de capteurs pour
adapter normalement les rythmes de
production en fonction de leur pic
émotionnel on en pense ce que l'on veut
mais une intelligence artificielle aussi
intrusive sous couvert d'adapter les
rythmes de travail au bien-être des
travailleurs pose tout de même de
véritables questions éthiques et
sécurité alors j'aimerais vous demander
à vous est ce que vous vous seriez
vraiment prêt à sacrifier une part de
vos intimité au confort offert par
l'intelligence artificielle
en parlant de confort justement j'ai un
rapport un petit peu particulier avec
celui là je viens de vous parler de
l'intelligence artificielle et je crois
qu'il est temps que je vous explique
pourquoi je vais vous parler de liberté
je suis atteinte d'un syndrome d'ehlers
danlos alors je vous l'écris là parce
qu'on peut vite entendre le nom d'un
meuble en kit suédois ce qui serait pas
totalement faux et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire avoir un syndrome d'ehlers-danlos
et bien ça veut dire que j'ai mal tout
le temps et que mon corps est si fragile
que mes articulations un petit peu
impolie ne savent pas du tout se tenir
et tente de se déboîter d'exil de
tourner j'avoue j'en ai un petit peu
bavé j'ai commencé par être attaché
pendant des semaines en grand écart très
petit j'ai pu passer quelques mois de ma
vie totalement immobilisé et j'ai
collaboré pendant quelques années avec
ave un fauteuil roulant
j'ai tenté d'être aveugle sourde bref
j'ai bien j'ai vraiment bien compris
l'importance et surtout la chance
d'avoir notre autonomie bon il ya
quelques avantages avoir un syndrome
d'ehlers danlos les symptômes sont
tellement hétéroclite
j'adore ce mot que j'ai vraiment pas le
temps de m'ennuyer et puis la douleur
cette fameuse douleur eh bien elle vous
cherche à jouer
elle vous pousse pardon à chercher à
l'intérieur de vous même des sortes d'
espaces de respiration lorsque le corps
n'en peut plus et c'est là que j'ai
trouvé ma propre liberté
et c'est avec ça que je viens vous
parler aujourd'hui
j'ai dû devenir un peu plus créative
sans doute pour m'adapter
cette situation cela explique
certainement pourquoi je suis devenu
architecte et designer et comme je suis
un peu technophiles pas techno addict et
bien je me suis intéressé aux
technologies émergentes
d'abord les réalités virtuelles puis
ensuite évidemment l'intelligence
artificielle et j'y vois de véritables
nouvelles matières à concevoir des
véritables opportunités de vaud
médiation mais je sens de manière
viscérale que il ya un véritable risque
pour notre indépendance alors en 2017
j'ai décidé de me consacrer à la
recherche et donc j'ai donné mon
entreprise à mes supers employés et j'ai
cherché de nouvelles façons d'agir et de
manière extraordinaire j'ai rencontré
d'autres fous qui avaient eux aussi
besoin d'agir de changer leur façon de
faire enfin avec la société et avec les
technologies alors en une soirée
on a décidé de créer un laboratoire
citoyen une sorte de ng up pour créer de
nouvelles sont de nouvelles façons de
faire société
nous sommes persuadés que l'intelligence
artificielle mais surtout l'intelligence
collective sont deux lames qui vont
profondément transformé notre monde
nous croyons que la collaboration est
une condition sinequanone pour répondre
aux grands défis de notre civilisation
nous voyons l'ia au service du bien
commun et pour cela on fait au quotidien
des événements des ateliers des groupes
d'apprentissage pour apprendre les
enjeux des nouvelles technologies tout
en assimilant de nouvelles méthodes de
faire ensemble
nous accompagnons également certaines
organisations qui ont décidé de changer
de façon de faire leur mode de
gouvernance ou utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle à bonne escient et pour
aller plus loin on développe une section
de recherches pour créer bientôt des
intelligences artificielles qui pourront
faciliter la collaboration
l'apprentissage
et on réfléchit à comment appliquer
toutes ces nouvelles technologies au
service du bien commun
et vous comment vous voudriez vous voir
évoluer le monde avec ses technologies
vous vous souvenez de vos deux tâches au
début et bien avec ça j'aimerais que
vous imaginiez une société qui
utiliserait sa technologie avec sagesse
car certes l'intelligence artificielle
pourrait absorber progressivement nos
libertés individuelles au profit d un d
autre du marché de la donner d'un
éventuel confort appuyer sur notre
dépendance
mais si elle est bien utilisée elle
pourrait bien nous rendre le temps
nécessaire à nous épanouir le temps
nécessaire à être pleinement humain
imaginez imaginez une intelligence
artificielle qui serait une sorte de
prolongement doux de nous mêmes un
entrelacement sobre et précis entre
technique et biologiques ou lit à
s'intégrer de manière fluide les
discrètes dans un système un permanent
est vivant imaginons qu'on revienne à
l'essentiel reprendre du temps pour
apprendre et se connaître donner du
temps pour faire les transmettre nous
pourrions laisser à lire ce qui nous
éloigne de notre humanité lui délégués
n'ont pas nos parent est comme dirait
damasio mais lui rendre ce qui nous
entrave est conservée pour nous ce qui
nous épanouie aimé apprendre transmettre
et prendre soin aimé apprendre
transmettre prendre soin je crois
sincèrement que l'intelligence
artificielle pourrait être le support
d'une transformation profonde et
humaniste comme l'écriture a permis
l'instruction mais pour ça il faut s'en
donner les moyens et nous allons devoir
ensemble créer un univers d'idées
positif
pour pouvoir le faire émerger car
baigner dans des projections du futur
s'est laissé progressivement existait
alors pour ça je vous propose trois
choses la première c'est d'être vigilant
austin numérique que vous allez utiliser
qui servent est il vraiment crée-t-il de
la dépendance ou de l'indépendance la
deuxième plus sympa c'est de vous
laisser imaginer les solutions vertueuse
celle dont on a vraiment besoin avec
l'intelligence artificielle et d'en
parler autour de vous enfin plus intimes
je vous invite à chercher à l'intérieur
de vous même ce qui est vraiment
essentiel ce qui vous épanouie et
lorsque vous l'aurez trouvait à les
aider et soutenir les projets qui vont
dans ce sens
la route risque d'être longue on va
avoir besoin de courage mais pour le
moment la voix est encore libre
quelquefois ferons nous je ne sais pas
comment vous appelez je ne sais pas si
ce soir nous allons pouvoir changer le
monde mais j'aimerais que ce soir en
sortant vous ayez follement envie d'être
libre libre d'être humain merci
[Applaudissements]